vertiefen wir das ganze mit dem
CDU-Generalsekretär Mario cire ist unser
Gast guten Morgen schönen guten Morgen
hallo das Bürgergeld wird heute im
Bundesrat an der Union scheitern korrekt
die CDU regierten Länder werden sich
heute aller Vorsicht nach enthalten so
haben sie signalisiert weil die
cdu-seite von diesen Bürgergeld von
ihrem aufgeben von fordern und fördern
nichts hält wir halten das für falsch
die Langzeitarbeitslosen werden auch
aufgegeben mit diesem Gesetz und
deswegen haben wir eine andere Position
und da wir uns dann in den Ländern
enthalten für das nicht zu der
notwendigen Zustimmung die die
Bundesregierung braucht und deswegen
wird der Vermittlungsausschuss mit
ziemlicher Sicherheit kommen müssen also
kurz gesagt ja stimmt Herr Czaja ihre
Kritik am Bürgergeld kann man schon
fragwürdig finden auf der einen Seite
werfen sie der Bundesregierung vor durch
das Bürgergeld lohne es sich nicht mehr
arbeiten zu gehen und auf der anderen
Seite wollen sie die Sätze auch erhöhen
verschärfen sie danach eigener Logik
nicht das Problem dass sie eigentlich
kritisieren
nein wir müssen unterscheiden wir sagen
nehmt nicht die Grundsicherungsempfänger
in Geiselhaft wir müssen den Regelsatz
erhöhen zum ersten ersten deswegen haben
wir letzte Woche schon in den Deutschen
Bundestag eingebracht dass der
Hartz-IV-Satz wir allgemeinsprachlich
gebraucht wird dass der erhöht wird auf
die 500 und 2 Euro das halten wir für
zwingend erforderlich und auf der
anderen Seite wird Fördern und Fordern
aufgegeben es gibt das wird ja nicht
aufgegeben doch es gibt sechs Monate
vertrauenszeit dann kommen noch mal
zwölf Monate kooperationszeit dazu da
muss zwischen dem hilfe-empfänger und
dem Jobcenter einen Vertrag gemacht
werden der dann von einer Schiedsstelle
überprüft wird ob der eingehalten wird
oder nicht wissen Sie auf einen
Beschäftigten im Jobcenter kommen 150
Hilfebedürftige dazu das ist überhaupt
nicht zu schaffen und damit wird das
aufgegeben dieses hohe Schonvermögen
ohne dass es 150.000 Euro für eine
vierköpfige Familie ohne dass eine
Kategorie stattfindet jemand der noch
gar nicht gearbeitet hat hat eben keinen
schon Vermögen oder sehr wenig und
jemand der viel gearbeitet hat mehr das
wird vollständig aufgeben dieses
Bürgergeld ist ungerecht und die
Menschen Gedanken im Land auch das
stimmt was nicht ganz ehrlich wie viele
vierköpfige Familien mit 150.000 Euro
Vermögen die dann leistungsberechtigt
sind kennen sie denn nee eben gerade
nicht und das ist das entscheidende es
wird ein Schonvermögen eingeführt und
damit eben auch ein falscher Anreiz zu
geben 50 Prozent derer die die diese
Langzeitarbeitslosen sind doch in der
Regel keine Barbestände sondern das sind
dann möglicherweise ist es ein Haus das
jetzt gerade in der Situation in der
immobilienlage nach oben gewertet wird
das stimmt genau nicht es steht drin
dass das eigengenutzte Haus ist das eine
die Altersvorsorge das andere und dann
geht es noch einmal um das schon
vermögen es sind drei unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe wie man überhaupt auf die
Idee kommen kann ein solches
Schonvermögen in ein Gesetz zu schreiben
was kaum jemand hat von denen die dieses
Bürgergeld erarbeiten das ist ja nicht
von uns Politikern dieses Geld sondern
es ist von den Menschen die täglich
arbeiten dafür hart schuften dieses Geld
einzahlen und das kommt den 2,6
Millionen zugute und wir wollen
diejenigen mehr gefördert und gefördert
werden um in Arbeit zu kommen wir haben
1,9 Millionen offene Stellen in
Deutschland und wenn man fördern und
fordern so aufgibt und solche falsch
Anreize setzt dann können wir da
deutlich nicht mitmachen argumentiert
natürlich die ampelseite natürlich wird
Fördern und Fordern nicht aufgegeben
ganz im Gegenteil das hat auch heute
morgen noch mal die
spd-ministerpräsidentin aus
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Schwesig
bekräftigt geht natürlich auch davon aus
dass das heute nicht wird weil sie eben
blockieren was bedeutet das dann für den
Vermittlungsausschuss wo liegen ihre
Kompromisslinien also vielleicht beim
Schonvermögen vielleicht können wir das
konkret machen sie haben ja gerade die
Summen auch genannt also bleiben wir
darf ich noch mal ganz kurz zum Fördern
und Fordern kommen die Bundesregierung
selbst hat Christian Lindner hat als
Finanzminister die Eingliederungshilfe
reduziert um 600 Millionen Euro das ist
das Geld was dafür da ist um
langzeitarbeitshose wieder ein Jobs zu
bringen es geht darum
Langzeitarbeitslose dauerhaft zu
alimentieren das ist die Idee die die
SPD dahinter hat faktisch hat sie sie
aufgegeben und wir möchten Sie gerne
wieder in Verbindung bringen mit Jobs
denn es sind ja nicht diejenigen die
kurzfristig arbeitslos geworden sind
sechs Monate zwölf Monate 24 Monate
sondern wir reden über
langzeitarbeitshose die Hälfte davon
sind die Hälfte davon haben
Migrationshintergrund brauchen weitere
Integrationshilfe sprach Kitas
abgeschafft Eingliederungshilfe
abgeschafft das zeigt doch deutlich
wohin es geht wir möchten Fördern und
Fordern behalten wir möchten dass viel
mehr gefördert wird und die Mitarbeiter
in den Jobcentern Zeit haben für die
Vermittlung wir möchten das beim
Schonvermögen Gerechtigkeit herrscht und
diejenigen die länger gearbeitet haben
ein höheres Schonvermögen haben als jene
die noch nie gearbeitet also wo da das
schon Vermögen liegt und wer ist vor
allen Dingen hat und wer da in Frage
kommt da gibt es ja unterschiedliche
Punkte und Bezugspunkte auch dazu aber
wir müssen jetzt mal nach vorne schauen
wenn es am ersten kommen soll also am 1
Januar das Bürgergeld und Sie haben ja
offenbar auch ein Interesse daran dass
es dann kommt was muss dann oder wann
muss dann spätestens ein Ergebnis im
Vermittlungsausschuss erzielt werden 25
November das war heute die Aussage von
Manuela Schwesig also wir haben ja dem
der Bundesregierung den Vorschlag
unterbreitet die Dinge zu entkoppeln die
Erhöhung des Regelsatzes als einen
anderen Bestandteil zu machen das haben
wir letzte Woche schon den Deutschen
Bundestag eingebracht da hat die
Regierung dagegen gestimmt wir werden
das nächste Woche wieder in den
Deutschen Bundestag so einbringen weil
wir den Regelsatz von dem systemumstieg
Abkoppeln möchten es kann nicht sein
dass jetzt die Hilfebedürftigen in
Geiselhaft genommen werden von der ja
aber es passiert eben leider deswegen
sagen wir wir haben gar keinen Druck
diese Reform jetzt in Schweinsgalopp
durch die Parlamente zu bringen denn
andersrum sie sagen das so dass Kritik
andersrum sie spielen die Ärmsten der
Gesellschaft gegeneinander aus genau das
tun wir nicht weil wir deutlich machen
wir wollen den Regelsatz erhöhen aber
wir wollen über diese grundsätzlichen
Dinge wo kann man sagt ja hundert Reform
20 Jahre haben wir nichts größeres
gehabt das kann man nicht in binnen von
ein zwei Wochen
wenn das nicht voneinander entkoppelt
wird so wie Sie sich das wünschen dann
wird es zum ersten Januar nicht kommen
deswegen schlagen wir ja vor dass es
entkoppelt wird wir haben es in den
Bundestag eingebracht und es kann gerne
wieder zugestimmt werden vielen Dank für
den Besuch hier bei uns das war der
CDU-Generalsekretär das klingt alles
nach verhärteten Fronten heute wird das
Bürgergeld im Bundesrat wohl nicht
durchgehen danke schön